welcome to good works tractors
guys how we doing today we are going to
compare category 1 quick itches
versus category 2. so you're going to
see a cat one on both of these outside
machines right here
you'll see them in red these are all
speako quick hitches you're also going
to see one tucked down here as well
we'll get to that in just a minute
so if you're in the market for a quick
hitch or you just want to make it easier
to attach your three-point
implements right up to your tractor pay
attention stick around
watch this maybe it'll save you some
money maybe it'll save you some
frustration we have two different
category one quick hitches and then
over here we're gonna have a category
two quick hitch so the main difference
besides the color between these two
quick hitches right here
both being category one as this is going
to be the really popular version that
does not use
bushings you can see this right here for
any attachment that you have with a
traditional style of quick hitch
you're going to need to put a set of
bushings on every implement so if you
have a box blade
a rear blade a ballast box a tiller a
brush hog all that kind of stuff
you need to get a set of these bushings
to put on every single attachment and
that can get really expensive
with a quick hitch like this you avoid
this no more bushings required it's a
direct
pin size here i don't know the answer
why bushings have been required for
years and years on all the traditional
style of category one quick hitches but
no more you don't need it however when
we get into the category two
sizing you are going to have to use
bushings there's not an option
for a direct pin fitment on the category
two so you need a set of these
or sometimes you have the kind of the
clevis hook on a three-point hitch
where you have two pieces of steel and
then a pin in between there
you'd have a different style of bushing
but regardless a bushing is going to be
required
so how do you know if you need a
category one or a category two
well it's pretty simple really so when
you think about a category one that's
going to be what's on your tractor the
three-point hitch that's back there
and so if you have a 10-25-hour or even
all the way up to a 40-66-r
that's all going to be category one
equipment so sub compacts and compact
tractors
once you're starting to get into five
series tractors like this
utility tractors that's when you're
gonna be into category two
you're even gonna see some that are a
cat one cat two kind of
little crossover type of thing there it
can get a little bit tricky with one of
those
stick around to later in the video or
read the description below as well
you'll want to pay attention to all the
dimensions the left to right spacing the
up to down spacing even the gaps in
between the arms of the quick hitch
check that against what you have on your
machine there to make sure it's going to
work for you
so whatever category your tractor is
means that's going to be what size
attachments hook up to it so if you have
a category 2 machine like this one here
you're going to hook up category 2
attachments same thing if it's a cat 1
machine you're gonna hook up category
one attachments to it
these two category one quick hitches
here are gonna weigh right around 70
pounds give or take an ounce or two
when you get up to the category two
that's going to weigh in at a whopping
134 pounds how we've been shipping out
these category one quick hitches is
going to be
wrapping them up we don't put them in a
box we don't do anything like that we've
had really good success just wrapping
them up with
corner protection and bubble wrap and
shrink wrap or stretch strap and sending
them out ups ground
once you get up to the category 2 though
it starts to get a little bit cumbersome
to try to wrap that up
and have ups come here and pick those up
so i think what we're gonna do
is start shipping those out on a really
small pallet if you can find a location
a commercial loading dock or maybe even
have it picked up at a shipping terminal
those are gonna be the cheapest ways to
ship these products right here the
category two
so in particular if you're thinking
about getting a category two we're all
gonna be shipping a pallet there anyways
if you wanna fit some other products on
there like
wheel weights suitcase weights maybe a
set of pallet forks something along
those lines
it can be really economical and be a
really good savings going to a
commercial address with a loading dock
or even picking up at the destination
terminal
give you a real quick rundown here of
what these quick hitches include they
are all a little bit different on what's
included i don't know why
the most popular version here the
category one e hitch by spiko is not
going to require any bushings therefore
no bushings are included
the other goofy thing is it doesn't
include a top pin one of these can be
purchased from like a tsc
farm and flee online on amazon very easy
it's just a pretty standard pin here
that you have in the top but just want
to make sure you know about that over
here on the more traditional style of
category one quick hitch
you are gonna have a set of bushings
that is included you are also going to
have the top pin here
and then even this little funny looking
contraption right here which is called a
floating top link adapter
this is really designed to be used in
place of a top hook it'll kind of hang
down like this
and you can hook up maybe a non quick
hitch compatible attachment to it over
here on the category 2 quick hitch you
are going to get a set of bushings again
like this and if you have the clevis
style that has again the two pieces of
steel with a pin in between
this doesn't work on there but there are
a lot of attachments out there that do
use this style of bushing
you are also not going to get that top
pin on this version either
so make sure you pay attention it's
gonna be a little bit bigger pin size a
category two pin size
that you wanna have for your category
two quick hitch this video idea came
about because of a lot of questions from
customers that have or want a solution
maybe to
having a category one and category two
quick hitch compatible
quick hitch and i don't really know a
product that exists like that and that's
where the dimensional spacing
really comes into play it's true that a
lot of the the quick hitches out there
require
bushings on there that are going to size
it up to a category 2 or category 3.
talking about these things right here
they take if it's a category one pin
that's on your attachment they size it
up to something larger than that however
there's spacing that's involved that
becomes a real issue that's what we're
going to talk about now
so here's where the challenge lies is
particularly
particularly the lower dimensions okay
you're inner to inner out of the outer
doesn't matter
on a category two quick hitch your id
okay
from inside to inside is 32 and three
quarter inches
you bounce over to one of these category
1 quick hitches it's going to be 27 and
a quarter a full 5 inches
narrower or larger but a 5 inch
difference there and so that's going to
be why a category 1
attachment doesn't fit into a category 2
quick hitch and vice versa you
also have variation between the lower
links to the top links on the category 2
here it's going to be
just a hair under 15 inches from the
bottom link down here
to the top link on the category 2 it is
welded in place this top hook presumably
to add more
structure rigidity strength to the
overall system on the category one quick
hitch you're gonna have a range for that
top hook you know a max height a lowest
point
you're gonna have basically 14 and a
half inches at the minimum
to and a 17.5 inches so you have three
inches of play room wiggle room from the
bottom to the top
gonna give you a couple quick dimensions
here both on the hooks and then also
back to the id
on the inside of where you would mount
one of these quick edges to your
three-point hitch
on a category two quick hitch these
hooks measure
about one and three quarter inches wide
over on the category one
these links are going to measure oh just
shy of one and a quarter inches
the last dimension i want to give you is
actually going to be the id right in
here where the quick hitch attaches to
the three-point arm
and this question or this dimension i
guess i'm giving it to you because i've
had a few folks
that have actually had a stabilizer arm
that doesn't come back and tie in
somewhere mid-point on the three-point
arm it actually comes all the way out
and would tie in with a pin right up
here kind of unusual and it took me a
little while to catch on to that
but they were concerned about having
enough space inside here to not only
have the three-point arm come but also
their stabilizer arm come up
and fit in there and then have a pin
slide through and connect it all so if
we take a look down here
on the inside of a category one quick
hitch your id
of where that lower link is gonna go in
there is gonna be
an inch and not even three quarters
probably an inch and
11 16 it looks like over here on a
category two quick hitch we take a look
here at the id
and you're gonna have about an inch and
seven eighths
not quite 15 16. well hopefully that
helps you know again if you have a
category one tractor even as large as a
4066 r or something equivalent to it
it's category one it's really simple get
yourself one of these guys or if
if you want to use the bushings go ahead
and get one of these down here
down to a little 10 25 little subcompact
doesn't matter kubota mahendra massey
coyote you name it they're all going to
use those category 1.
if you're into a larger utility style of
tractor category 2 that's going to be
what you want
unfortunately there's going to be that
small gap that's kind of a crossover
you get to some of the smaller 5 series
like a john deere
50 45e something like that or an mx
series in kubota something equivalent to
that you're going to have that category
1 category 2 crossover
if you have category 1 attachments and
also category 2 attachments you're going
to have to get really creative on
finding a solution to make them all mate
up with one quick hitch again because of
the spacing
it's not only spacing that's on the
quick itches here it's also spacing
that's on the
corresponding attachments that you had
that hook up to the three point
now don't forget goodworks tractors.com
go ahead check them out on there
shoot me an email we can place the order
with you we ship them all over the
country all the time
these smaller ones again we can ship
them ups ground right to your house
you get one of these category twos it's
gonna have to ship on a skid
a small skid you know if you can find
that commercial address or
the the local destination terminal to
pick it up at those are typically your
cheapest options
if you want to maximize the shipping
savings stack a lot of stuff onto that
same little skid there
and you'll really minimize that savings
when you spread it out across all the
equipment you're buying
if you would take a second give a thumbs
up a thumbs down and also subscribe to
the channel that would really help us
out
read through that description below for
all sorts of helpful links on cool stuff
for tractor owners and check out the
other videos on the channel until next
time
stay safe we'll see you soon